we're only a few months away from the
return of our favorite fast-talking
regenerating degenerate Deadpool and we
finally got our first look at Josh
Brolin's cable and all his tactical
pouches in the first real trailer
fortunately there's plenty of other
stuff to dig into to follow along if
you're unafraid of spoilers as we break
down everything you missed in the
Deadpool 2 trailer redeye the trailer
opens with our first look at Josh
Brolin's Cable aka Nathan summers the
character has been a beloved mainstay of
the x-men comics since his first adult
appearance in 1990 and his glowing eye
is as much of a calling card for him as
it is for his optic blast shooting
father based on his ongoing narration
about being born in a war we can surmise
that the movie will at least partially
follow summers original origin as the
time displays son of Scott Summers and
Jean Grey's clone raised in a dystopian
future more machine than man in the
comics cable is one of the most powerful
mutants in the multiverse but his
potential is dampened by the
techno-organic virus given to him as a
child by the evil mutant apocalypse the
virus was meant to kill him but he was
saved by a talking ship in a one-way
trip to the future where he learned to
keep the constantly spreading
techno-organic virus confined to his
left arm and I albeit at the expense of
the full strength of his telekinetic
powers whether Deadpool too will follow
the convoluted story is anyone's guess
but in recent iterations cable is used
to tricked-out metal arm for added
combat effectiveness after being cured
of the original virus so it could go
either way
hope although the trailer didn't give
away any main plot points the appearance
of a battered teddy bear on cables hip
has led to speculation that one of the
storylines Deadpool 2 may be adapting
his cable stewardship of Hope Summers
unlike the rest of the Somers family
hope isn't actually related to Scott
even though she bears a striking
resemblance to Jean Grey
instead she was the first mutant born in
a world that had the mutant genome
removed by the scarlet witch's chaos
magic power regardless Hope Summers has
been referenced previously when her name
appeared in the first teaser back in
2017 up to 11 what's the most pain
you've ever felt
we're not sure who cables asking but
odds are good that his gun is about to
cause more pain than the most they've
ever felt cranking it to 11 is a great
use of the immortal gag from this is
spinal tap why don't you just make 10
louder and make 10 be the top number and
make that a little lower these car to 11
but even better it's a pretty perfect
encapsulation of cable as a character in
concept he's the most hardcore mutant in
the world of course his dials go past 10
not a mustache one of the best gags in
the trailer is a snide joke that makes
fun of Warner Brothers digitally erasing
Henry cavils mustache for Justice League
it's a mustache based on what we saw of
the mustache Liske Avalanche ustus
League a metal arm really might be
easier to make that said the best end
joke from the trailer is still Deadpool
mocking Josh Brolin's other Marvel
character Thanos and his quest for the
Infinity stones I got the stones to help
you Domino we also get our first look at
Domino played by ZZ beats this is the
first time Domino has made it to the big
screen although like cable she's been a
fan favorite for years in the comics
she's a consistent member of the x-force
the secret strike team of the ex family
she's an expert at shooting and stabbing
but her best quality on any team is her
mutant ability which encourages good
luck around her and means things usually
tend to just work out we can expect
Deadpool to make at least a couple of
jokes about her mutant power being lazy
writing but he'd better hope she's on
his side another detail that the movie
may or may not address is that she also
had a brief fling with another character
appearing in Deadpool 2 Colossus
negasonic teenage warhead
one of the standout characters in the
original Deadpool was definitely
negasonic teenage warhead it looks like
she's back for the sequel
she's grown her hair out a bit but she
looks his punk and angsty as she was in
the original so we should get some great
interplay between her and Wade Wilson
new team
in a blink and you'll miss it moment we
see Deadpool in a plane flanked like
Domino Terry Crews and too hard to see
mutants it's possible that Cruz could be
playing Bishop the other time-traveling
mutant on the x-men but he's usually
working against cable and is rarely been
on x-force it's more likely that he's
playing either hammer or GW bridge both
frequent cable allies easier to spot is
what looks like shatter star standing
between Deadpool and Cruz in the comics
he's a gladiator from a future dystopia
called mojo world in between Domino and
Deadpool looks like what could be
chamber a mutant who drew the short
straw of mutant powers with a bio energy
that constantly leaks from his lower
face and throat side characters it isn't
just mutants that are coming back for
the sequel blind al
Vanessa weasel and dopinder are all seen
in the Deadpool 2 trailer but we'll have
to see how much time they get on screen
was such a packed cast as far as Wade's
unpowered supporting cast goes one
character is decidedly absent Bob the
agent of Hydra who was slyly referenced
in the original wait well I have to see
if Disney's lawyers have softened up
enough to let Bob appear in Deadpool 2
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]